et faut en parler nous sommes avec
augusto lunar dix journalistes au brésil
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur rt france quelle est la nature
de la de la démission du ministre de la
santé il ya vraiment deux points de vue
finalement sur la gestion de cette crise
au brésil ou pas oui exactement on sait
que le contexte est très compliqué le
timing n'était pas le meilleur mais ce
divorce n'est pas du tout une surprise
au brésil car le ministre de la santé
qui s'appelle louis demande état et
bolton arrow étaient un total des
accords comme vous l'avez dit sur la
lutte contre le coran navires us au
brésil molson araud a même dit que le
ministre essayait de de prendre toutes
les lumières vers lui et qui essayait de
enfin que le pouvoir lui a fait monter
la tête et mon état a toujours préconisé
le confinement complet total dans le
pays
il a toujours suivi à la lettre les
recommandations de l oms s qui n'était
pas du tout le cas de gm golden arrow et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le ministre
de la santé est devenu une sorte de
héros dans le pays
76% des brésiliens étaient contre sa
démission mais bon ça ne rentre là quand
même fait est juste après l'annoncé de
son limogeage les brésiliens donc
plusieurs villes du pays se sont mis à
leur fenêtre pour un concert de
casseroles pour manifester contre la
démission du ministre de la santé en
criant bolton à rodez gars jouent à leur
bol sonar au génocide
même le président brésilien a tout de
même limogé le
l'ancien dans l'ancien ministre de la
santé il ya déjà choisi son nouveau
ministre de la santé qui lui n'a pas
évoqué le confinement la fin du
confinement qui est déjà installée par
plusieurs gouverneurs dans le pays mais
ce qui est très contradictoire avec son
discours car le nouveau ministre de la
santé a dit qu'il était un parfait
alignement avec jacques bolson haro donc
on sait pas exactement sur sur qui on
attend beyoncé pas à quoi s'attendre
dans les semaines à venir
oui puisque concrètement les brésiliens
se confine domaine j'imagine comment ça
se passe justement puisque le président
venu justement que l'économie ne
s'arrête pas comment faire pour aller
travailler
alors le confinement il est partiel les
gouverneurs il faut savoir que le brésil
est un pays un peu comme les etats-unis
ou l'allemagne ou les états ne dépendent
pas du président de la république qui
peuvent instaurer ses propres lois ou
ses propres décisions
donc la totalité des 27 états brésiliens
ont déclaré confinement ou à leur
confinement partiel c'est-à-dire la
fermeture des commerces non essentiels
donc le problème c'est qu'avec ce double
discours du président de la république
et le ministre de la santé les
brésiliens sont complètement perdus et
se sentent même encouragé par le
président de la république et continue
d'aller dehors continue de travailler
donc le confinement la pâte tout à fait
respecté par tous les brésiliens ce qui
est très inquiétant et la situation
sanitaire est ce qu'elle est
préoccupante très court oui c'est très
inquiétant
on ne sait pas exactement ce qui va se
passer dans les prochaines semaines
il faut savoir qu'il ya déjà trente
mille cas dans le brésil plus de 2000
morts
mais les chercheurs s'attendent à une
hécatombe dans les prochaines semaines
parce que les chercheurs du coc vide au
brésil disent que ces chiffres seraient
quinze fois plus élevé on n'a pas à ces
tests au brésil donc on aurait peut-être
300 me cas confirmés au brésil sans
qu'on le sache et ça serait très
dramatique on saura dans les prochaines
semaines avec le nombre de morts
malheureusement merci beaucoup à vous
salle mardi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france